figaro live il est 19 heures
cinq exactement nous sommes le vendredi
13 novembre pour une semaine
particulièrement importantes n'ont pas
seulement puisque non seulement par
confinement et ce sera peut-être une
occasion d'exploiter ce que nous allons
vous expliquer dans les minutes à venir
mais plutôt parce que les consoles
nouvelle génération sortent cette
semaine avec d'abord et bien la xbox
série ce qui est sorti ce mardi mais
également la ps 5 qui va venir la
semaine prochaine et qu'on va vous faire
tester en même temps que sa sortie la
semaine prochaine donc rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour voir le
concurrent de ce que nous allons vous
présenter ce soir
ce soir je vous le disais nous testons
la nouvelle xbox series alors ce soir on
va tester la model x il ya également un
second modèle sur lequel on va revenir
très vite
ce que vous voyez sur vos écrans c'est
bien le dernier assassin's creed valia
qui vient se déroule dans l'air
scandinaves on va le vous présenter on
va vous présenter plusieurs jeux alors
les questions sont nombreuses qu'elles
sont là blé puis la puissance de la
console qu'elles sont le prix quelles
sont les différentes les différents
facteurs pardon de la console on va
revenir là-dessus avec vous en direct
pour ce soir on va prendre vraiment
toutes vos questions n'hésitez pas alors
avant tout et avant de commencer sachez
que ce que vous voyez sur vos écrans
n'exploite pas parfaitement le talent et
les compétences de la delà de la console
puisque nous sommes en 25 images par
seconde et non en 60 comme le permettent
le jeu donc le jeu est un petit peu
moins beau que ce qu'on pourrait voir
sachez le on préfère vous prévenir en
avance mais on est malheureusement
dépendant de la technique de la mise en
ligne sur internet pour tester cette
nouvelle console vous la connaissez
forcément si vous suivez les tests vidéo
ludique de du figaro nous sommes en
direct avec chloé boîtier bonsoir
clients ça va ça va très bien merci
d'être avec nous pour tester ce cette
nouvelle xbox on va revenir avec vous
sur toutes les sorties sur et bien
toutes les particularités qui font de
cette xbox peut-être une nouvelle
console nouvelle génération ou alors une
console de old school mais est sorti
très tard on va revenir sur tous ces
paramètres
pour commencer je vais déjà vous salue
et puisque nous sommes en direct sur la
page principale du figaro sur twitter
mais également sur youtube et je vais
vous saluer
à tous merci d'être avec nous je vais
même être exhaustif et vous saluer de
vassan % bonsoir les ni cool riz à doha
guy m6 déjà vu maxime reygades mercy
james est reckless sont encore ché merci
à tous n'hésitez pas à nous dire ce que
vous pensez de cette console si vous
l'avez commander si vous l'avez acheté
si vous ne souhaitez pas l'acheter si
vous êtes plutôt pour la concurrente ou
pas du tout pour aucune des deux tout à
l'heure je voyais des messages pci ceux
de best buy si au contraire vous êtes un
joueur pc n'hésitez pas à nous le dire
aussi en tout cas on prend tous vos
commentaires on peut même les faire
apparaître sur l'écran comme par exemple
ceux ce flux de ce commentaire de lily
cole qui nous dit qu'il était premier
voilà donc n'hésitez pas on est
interactif on est là pour réagir avec
vous et prendrait bientôt vos
commentaires merci à tous d'être avec
nous alors pour commencer
chloé là on est sur la xbox series x
mais il ya également la haye ce qu'est
sorti alors quelles sont les différences
entre ces deux consoles alors déjà une
grosse différence de prix la console
c'est la xbox série 6 qui est juste à
côté de moi
elle coûte 499 euros alors que la série
s elle est à seulement 299 euros donc
comment expliquer cette différence de
prix
alors il ya trois raisons principales la
première sur la xbox et reese x voilà
vous voyez ici c'est un lecteur de blu
ray qui est totalement absent de la
série s ce qui veut dire concrètement
que ça ne sert à rien d'acheter vos jeux
au format physique sur la si vous
achetez la série s car on voit que vous
n'aurez nulle part pour rentrer cccd il
faut tout acheter au format
dématérialisé donc tout acheter sur le
microsoft store et ça c'est pas anodin
parce que sur le prix des jeux en fait
vous allez être dépendant des prix de la
politique tarifaire du microsoft store
alors certes il ya régulièrement des
promotions sur ce store comme qui a
également des promotions sur le psn mais
rarement sur les jeux qui viennent de
sortir
donc les gens qui viennent de sortir ils
sont à 70 euros alors que on sait que
dans la grande distribution
on peut trouver des jeux neufs qui
viennent tout juste de sortir le jour de
leur sortie est plutôt à 60,50 voir des
fois 45 euros
si jamais vous êtes un petit peu serré
au niveau budget je vous conseillerais
certes elle coûte 200 euros plus cher
mais vous allez très vite la
rentabiliser sur le long sur le même le
moyen terme
si vraiment vous souhaitez acheter
plutôt des confins des jeux plutôt à 40
euros plutôt que 70 ça c'est la première
différence d'accord la deuxième
différence et la capacité de stockage
ici nous avons un disque dur qui fait un
espoir un ssd pardon un ssd donc il
permet de
d'enregistrer pour un théâtre donnée
alors que sur la série s l'espace de
stockage est beaucoup plus petit je
crois qu'il est quasiment moitié moins
grand dans ce qui fait que les jeux
étant quand même très volumineux par
exemple le forza je vous montrais tout à
l'heure c'est 90 giga lui tout seul bon
bah vous remplissez quoi votre disque
dur très très vite
si jamais vous optez pour la s et enfin
la dernière différence ça va être une
différence de puissance
la série s est moins puissante
les images ne seront pas en véritable
quatre cas d'accord et donc ce sera un
poil moins jolie un poids moins
puissants donc ça n'a pas non plus
exploiter au maximum les capacités de la
console alors que la série x par contre
se présente comme étant la console voilà
la plus au top possible techniquement
donc bas qui seraient en cours ce modèle
a une puissance similaire à celle de la
ps1 cas d'accord ça servait à l'époque
les trois grandes différences selon les
modèles on va on va revenir on va
revenir là dessus avant ça je vous salue
vous qui nous rejoignent et sur la page
principale du figaro sur youtube ou sur
twitter merci de vos commentaires
n'hésitez pas à réagir si vous avez des
questions en particulier ou des points
que vous souhaitez qu'on aborde en
premier n'hésitez pas on le fera avec
grand plaisir
je vois en tout cas vos réactions et vos
questions notamment vous rétro gaming
n'y a pas pas alors on est loin des
nouvelles générations avec rétro gaming
mais il faudra surtout une extension de
mémoire pour stocker les jeux sur la s
c'est vrai que les jeux étaient déjà
très volumineux sur les précédentes
consoles on verra comment ça se passe
pour les futurs mais on peut s'attendre
à des tailles assez importante
on a dream ce qui donne à l extension de
mémoire donc oui vous pouvez acheter une
extension de mémoire ram et ses 270
euros pour intérêt de données mais ça
c'est du ces du mat ou ces deux là c'est
du cloud non non c'est une extension que
vous branchez sur la pression ok mais
270 euros
alors on à jim celle qui nous dit avec
le pass pas besoin d'acheter des jeux on
va revenir sur quatre fonctionnalités du
sur cette fonctionnalité du de là
game place du game passe et on nous
demande aussi pourquoi on a démasqué
bien il va falloir voir un psy et les
particularités de notre période
voilà en ayant mené à côté donc on
essaye de respecter les consignes
sanitaires en vigueur
alors on est on voit cette console qui
est un pavé assez énorme avec lequel on
peut construire des murs des murs cercle
très fermé qui est quand même assez
grosse c'est quoi les particularités
physiques de cette console
elle est lourde elle pèse on se met en
pause le jeu elle pèse 4,5 kg dont je
peux vous dire que vous le sentez quand
même faire grand chose mais vous le
sentez quand vous devez la transporter
notamment de chez vous jusqu'à la
rédaction
donc voilà elle et elle est quand même
assez lourde aussi en fait la chaleur en
fait j'aimerais ça être dans
téléshopping la salle a en fait tu sors
par ici donc cette espèce de trou
grillage et donc la chaleur sorte par le
haut et c'est pour ça que je vous
déconseille formellement au temps de
mettre votre console dans un meuble télé
et 3 parce que même là elle est debout
vous pouvez la mettre où j'ai donc là ça
va sortir par la droite
d'accord mais elle devrait que la
chaleur qui sort ce à peu près 60 degrés
là ok oui donc éviter autant que
possible de mettre votre console wii
vous savez dans les petites niches donc
déjà si ça rentre dans les niches de
votre meuble télé et où voir par exemple
genre totalement coller à votre modem
totalement coléreux décodeur télé
notamment coller à une autre console
là ça va être la catastrophe donc si
jamais votre si vous pouvez c'est votre
pub télé assez grand mettez la sur le
meuble télé à côté de la télé du
téléviseur si vous pouvez pas mettez là
par terre contre le meuble télé parce
que bas il va falloir en fait que ça
sert énormément pour que ça fonctionne
bien donc ça certes c'est une contrainte
mais l' avantage c'est que la personne
et du silence d'accord ça répond
parfaitement à la question cathédrale 2
thomas elizabeth est ce que la console
fait du bruit quand on joue à valhalla
non donc voilà là elle est en train de
tout elle elle tourne à l'est sont bas
et là on entend strictement rien on a
même l'impression qu'elle est éteinte
tellement elle ne fait pas de bruit ça
fait ça fait une semaine que un peu plus
d'une semaine que j'ai mais oui plus que
ça ça va faire bientôt deux semaines que
j'ai là
ce box à la maison la xbox et rice s à
la maison je n'allais jamais entendu le
seul moment où vous l'entendez c'est
quand vous insérez un disque parce
qu'évidemment vous allez entendre le
lecteur de disque d'affaires moins bon
et ça peu près tout mais sinon on ne
l'entend jamais moulinet on l'entend
jamais partir dans les aigus n'entend
pas faire un bruit d'aspirateur comme
peuvent le faire les consoles actuelles
même surtout la xbox une ancienne xbox
qui était vraiment la ps4 la paix cela
doit être aussi extrêmement bruyante
là vous n'avez pas de bruit alors c'est
le début on verra dans d'ici un an ou
deux qu'on ait ce sera bien la crasse et
qui se lancent à leur tour qu'ils seront
tombés dedans quand il y aura des jeux
vraiment extrêmement puissant qui sont
sortis peut-être qu'on va entendre un
petit peu plus le ventilateur mais là
pour le moment c'est un silence
incroyable
alors on nous demande si on joue avec un
disque physique non là on est en démat
d'accord on est en démat façon tous les
jeux que je vais vous montrer
je les ai y soit en démat d'accord ben
voilà qui vous répond c'était jim celle
qui nous qui nous posait là la question
on a des questions aussi sur les bancs
on va prendre vos questions en dans
l'ordre n'hésitez pas un si on prend on
met un peu de temps à répondre à votre
question rester avec nous on essaie
vraiment de les prendre de façon
exhaustive ce sera avec grand plaisir
même les plus tordus je vais journée de
trois là qui viennent et que auquel on
va répondre aussi juste pour le principe
alors pour commencer on est une très
bonne question divers 9 quels sont les
exclus microsoft à venir j'ai envie de
dire il ya parlé
certaines des plus grosses exclus qui
vont venir avec le rachat d'une certaine
un compagnie par microsoft
ça ça reste à voir c'est vrai tu là on
va dire le problème du lancement de
cette de cette xbox et que les
exclusivités mais en fait y en a pas des
masses
voire même y en a pas du tout je
voudrais mène sur l'accueil du jeu donc
là en fait légaux les jeux qui
exploitent vraiment la puissance de la
xbox série x sait déjà que vous allez
retrouver sur playstation 5 d'accord
donc là par exemple
assassin's creed va là il sort sur
toutes les consoles
et là bon il ya kooza là que dragon's la
petite exception une version ps 5 est
prévue mais elle sortira l'année
prochaine mais il est sorti la sûreté
est ce cap
donc pour le moment vous n'avez pas de
jeux qui sont 100% xbox série x et les
jeux qui sont qui sortent
il n'y a pas du tout d'exclusivité
hormis cette étude étaient temporaires
sur yakuza
il n'y a pas de pas par exemple sur le
chez sony vous allez avoir spider man
vous allez avoir des modes solo et astro
boy astro playroom pardon à la troupe
les rom qui est un c qui de base dans la
console là chez microsoft n'y a pas
d'accord pourquoi ya pas parce que ça
devait être halo halo devait être
halloween finite je crois devait être le
gros jeu de lancement
problème comme vous savez c'est le cosy
de 19 et les équipes de production n'ont
pas réussi à finir dans les temps donc
on leur a laissé plus de plusieurs mois
encore pour lot pour peaufiner le jeu
pour le terminer non ce qui fait que
malheureusement il n'y a pas de vrais
moments de jeu on va dire flagship
vraiment le gros jeu microsoft qui voilà
bien les enjeux présentes les présidents
du xerox était sorti avec un gisement il
ya un lot à chaque fois la sortie
bon ben là ce sera pas le cas donc là
pour le moment fait il va falloir soit
prendre les versions next-gen des gros
jeux de la fin d'année donc là on aura
par exemple cyberpunk 2077 retarde aussi
retardé en décembre retardée en décembre
vous avez watchdogs lésions qui est
sorti la semaine dernière qui est
également disponible sur la série 6 là
vous avez assassin vous allez avoir call
of duty également qui sera qui sera
disponible vous avez damman les douves
les nouveaux fifa mais bon ça qu'au
niveau a exclu pour le moment on est un
peu on est un peu chiche mais ça c'est
pour 2020 en 2021 il y aura quand même
beaucoup plus de choses même si beaucoup
tous ne sont pas annoncés pour qu'on
sait qu'il ya à l'eau qui arrive mais
microsoft en fait tu as acheté
énormément de studios de développement
ces dernières années dont bethesda
d'accord
mais voilà ces studios là vont être
amenées évidemment à sortir des
exclusivités qui vont arriver dans les
mois à venir et pour la question de
bethesda j'anticipe pour le moment donc
btac les gens enfin christophe c zenimax
donc le groupe qui détient bethesda à
ubisoft wahid software arkane studios
donc c'est les gens qui sont derrière
doom qui sont d'ailleurs wolfenstein qui
sont derrière skyrim qui sont voilà
toute la série elder scrolls etc etc
les fallout aussi pour l'argent c'est
pas tranché ils ne disent pas que toutes
les nouveautés iront seulement sur
microsoft que les précédents les
précédents par exemple skyrim est sorti
à la fois sur switch iglesias mention
ps4 il est sorti absolument partout
skyrim même sont les caisses de verre
quand il sortit c'est vrai partout
donc on verra c'est possible qui aura
quand même des fenêtre d'exclusivité
microsoft mais bon pour le moment c'est
pas c'est pas encore très clair la
politique
alors on va revenir dans le chat pour
répondre à vos questions et à vos
commentaires vous êtes nombreux à vous
interroger je vous rappelle qu'on est en
direct sur la page principale du figaro
sur twitch et sur youtube pour y
répondre
n'hésitez pas à les poser même si on
doit se répéter dans ce sera avec
plaisir je vais les prendre dans le bon
sens n'hésitez pas à rester avec nous
aussi
si on prend un peu de temps à répondre à
vos questions comme vous êtes nombreux
et qu'on essaye d'être exhaustif ça
prend parfois un peu de temps mais voilà
on nous demande des questions nous
demandait alors je vais essayer de
retrouver cela puisque j'ai un peu
travaillé quand même pouvoir une façon
voilà on a les y lisent et fier qu'il me
demande le prix en francs cfa et bah je
peux y répondre
puisque cette console cher mesdames et
messieurs et à 327 1846 francs cfa voilà
vous voyez qu'on peut vraiment répondre
à toutes les questions non alors pour
revenir sur des questions plus sérieuses
dans le prix de cette console c'est donc
et pour répondre à beaucoup de questions
qui ont été posées et bien le prix de
cette console la version x état
499 euros la version s qui est donc une
version plus allégée sans lecteur blu
ray avec une absence d'affichage 4 cas
avec une taille un peu plus petit c'est
300 euros ce qui est un prix assez
acompte assez compétitifs pour une
console nouvelle génération
voilà en tout cas qui répond à pas mal
de vos questions au passage je vais vous
saluer julio cesar 976 mercy james head
est toujours avec nous makaveli de
junkie illuminatis thomas diabète
toujours qui est avec nous ni aux par
sival raphaël pk 85 merci à tous d'être
ici n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
vous voyez qu'on essaye d'y répondre le
plus possible alors qu'on vient de
basculer sur forza reisen nouvelle
génération alors je précise juste donc
ça c'est un jeu qui est sorti sur xbox
one mais qui a été patché pour la xbox
et risque d'accord donc avec 60 fps 4k
enfin bref toutes les petites des
déchets host et de la nouvelle
génération
donc voilà donc c'est une version
améliorée du jeu qui est sorti sur xbox
live alors pour répondre à thomas
elizabeth qui nous pose une question au
niveau de la manette on peut peut-être
présenter cette manette qui est assez
sensiblement identique à la précédente
mais est-ce que ça concerne également la
sensibilité et la prise en main comme
n'augmente contre mme elisabeth
thilleman ans qu'en est-il au niveau de
la prise en main de la manette est ce
que c'est comme la one
alors comme ça je vais vous la montrer à
l'écran ouais elle est quand même très
très sensiblement ressemblante à la
à la one ce que j'aime beaucoup moi sur
cette manne est donc là on ne verra pas
forcément mais c'est qui est un très
très bon grip
donc il ya un revêtement spécial qui
fait que ça accroche bien romain que ça
glisse pas sur tout ça ne transpire pas
ouais donc ça c'est super il ya
également un grip haut niveau au niveau
des gâchettes donc ce qui fait que
franchement la manette alors certains la
trouveront un peu plus compact que salo
les xbox one
c'est vrai qu'elle est un petit peu plus
petit bon moi ça me gêne pas pour pour
mes mains parce que voilà j'ai pas des
mains non plus super grande mais ça que
si on a des très grosses mains très
grandes mains peut-être que ça va un
petit peu gêné
d'accord mais sinon voilà on retrouve
bon il ya une très bonne croix
directionnelle là vous avez le boot le
fameux bouton share qui était absent sur
sur la boîte donc il vous permet de
faire des de prendre des captures
d'écran et des canaris en vidéo et en
europe sur playstation et pour moi en
fait alors ça peut pour moi c'est un
défaut pour d'autres ce sera une qualité
moi je le trouve que cette manette fait
beaucoup de bruit par exemple si
j'utilise les boutons de la tranche donc
je me rapproche du micro voilà pareil
pour l'amour à des acteurs j'espère que
ça son temps en ce qui concerne le bruit
est ce que c'est comme la ps4 à l'époque
est ce qu'il ya un interphone un parc
intégré qui peut interagir avec le jeu
à 6 lire cl du son qu'il n'y a pas de
sens qui semble à leur nette non il n'y
a pas de sens qu'ils sortent de la
manette par contre vous pouvez toujours
branché évidemment un calque votre son
botnet et un micro casque pour le jeu en
ligne ou même juste un casque et
d'ailleurs pour cette nouvelle
génération de consoles je vous
recommande chaudement de jouer au casque
parce que le travail sur le son est
assez dingue notamment sur assassin
royal a donc vous en profiterez
vachement mieux si vous avez un très bon
casque audio
enfin vraiment un casque audio sympa
bien qu'ils écoutent pas forcément une
fortune mais vous profiterez beaucoup
mieux de vos jeux si vous jouez comme ça
plutôt que sur les haut parleurs de vos
télévisions qui sont jamais géniaux
alors évidemment si vous avez une barre
de son oublier ce que je viens de vous
dire mais si vous n'avez pas ça a joué
plutôt au casque d'accord alors avant de
rentrer dans le dur des questions en ce
qui concerne la puissance de 7 x box
series x comparé à la puissance de la
série s mais aussi de la ps1 qu on va
revenir très légèrement sur ces points
donc n'hésitez pas à rester avec nous
avant je vois aussi quelques questions
sur la rétro comptabilité ça c'est une
question divers 9 mai également
je vais essayer de vous retrouver c'est
vous north ken 76 va merci de vos
questions alors dans ce cas une qui me
demande comment ça se passe au niveau de
l'arrêt compte la rétro compatibilité
des précédentes xbox possible en support
physique en streaming par téléchargement
qu'est ce qu'on peut leur répondre ah là
là c'est la fête
voilà ce que je vais vous répondre alors
le plus simple ce que je vous montre
mais je me joue des applications
hop accueil grosso modo cette console
est compatible avec toutes les
précédentes consoles de microsoft
donc toutes les consoles qui sortit
c'est qu'ils sont sortis ces vingt
dernières années
xbox xbox 360 xbox one et voilà ce qui
était ce qui est déjà pas mal
qu'est ce que ça veut dire concrètement
donc il y à il ya deux cas de figure
vous avez acheté vos jeux en version
physique il va falloir que vous si vous
avez il faut aussi absolument avoir la x
évidemment vu que la s n'a pas de
lecteur physique vous mettez vos jeu
dans le lecteur et a par contre le petit
problème notamment sur les jeux 360 j'ai
pas pu vérifier sur les jeux one parce
que je n'ai pas de jeu wayne en version
physique mais sur 360 vous allez devoir
la console va télécharger les jeux
en fait elle va se connecter au
microsoft store pour télécharger le jeu
elle va le chercher en fait votre disque
certes de clés de pros de preuve que
vous allez bien acheté le jeu mais il va
pas copier les données du disque
directement du disque vers le disque dur
d'accord ça c'est franchement dommage ça
veut dire qu'il faut avoir une exemption
60 encore en état de marche
non il faut une juge il faut des jeux
des jeux fait que vous voulez il faut
les jouer vous ayez toujours vos jeux il
doit 360 si vous les avez toujours la
console on s'en fiche la console vous a
laissée dans le placard vous la lavande
et ça ça vous pouvez vous en débarrasser
de vos consoles je n'avais plus besoin
ce dont on aurait besoin du coup c'est
les disques c'est vous les achetez en
dix mois
mais par contre voilà ça va se connecter
à internet pour télécharger les jeux
donc si vous avez une petite connexion
internet ça peut être un petit peu
problématique
ensuite vous avez acheté vos jeux à
l'époque de la 360 sur le xbox live
et bien pas de problème parce que l'on
en fait la console va aller rechercher
vient votre compte microsoft que
évidemment vous avez gardé le même qu'à
l'époque
eh ben il va voir tous vos achats de
l'époque et va vous proposer de re
télécharger vos jeux donc vous ne perdez
strictement rien donc moi pardon j'ai pu
redécouvrir que à huy tient en fait
j'avais acheté ce jeu là ouais j'avais
oublié que j'avais acheté de tels jeux
il ya plusieurs années et donc
donc ça peut être une paye avoir des
petites sur ce titre surprise parce que
moi bon je jouais autres xbox à la xbox
ensuite j'étais passé à la ps4 et donc
donc voilà donc oui il ya eu un gap de 7
ans et donc quand j'ai retrouvé les jeux
que j'avais acheté à l'époque ta vie d
un oui tiens c'est vrai c'est vrai il ya
ça mais ça marche plus très bien et
surtout le petit bonus c'est que les
jeux sont améliorées automatiquement par
rapport à ce qu'il était à l'époque en
fait la console va appliquer
automatiquement des filtres elle va
appliquer des effets hdr qu'il n'y avait
pas à l'époque donc des effets de
lumière des effets de couleurs qui font
que les jeux vont être plus beau qu'il
ne l'était à l'époque ils vont être plus
fin ils vont être du coup beaucoup plus
joli à regarder qu'il ne l'était alors
ça va pas non plus les transfigurer mais
disons que ça va être au niveau bas ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui un rig masters
donc je vais vous montrer par exemple
avec dead space jeu d'horreur un des
plus meilleurs jeux d'horreur jamais
sortir avec une trilogie derrière qui
est sorti 1 2 et en trois au passage
pendant que sa charge est ce qu'on peut
répondre à hiver neuf qu'il me demande
si les manettes one fonctionne avec
cette console wii ok mais il me semble
uniquement avec les jeux ouanna d'accord
mais en tout cas avec les jeux et
présente génération mais pas avec les
jeux actuels mais ça c'est à vérifier
mais de façon vous avez une manette vous
avez corporelle
alors voilà en tout cas pendant que ça
continue de charger merci à vous
logan hiver 9 encore julio cesar fabien
également je ne crois pas vous avoir
salué n'hésitez pas on prend toute
toutes vos questions que ce soit sur la
page principale du figaro sur tweets
chaud sur youtube
n'hésitez pas je vois pas mal de
questions de commentaires également
logan qui nous dit que pour le bon
système sont dont parlait chloé vous
êtes tout à fait d'accord au sujet que
ce soit du son sur mbo 6 sur call of two
sur battlefield on est obligé de jouer
avec du son avec un bon casque en effet
bon soir au passage à droff
bref qu'ils n'ont rejoint sur twitch
bienvenu merci d'être avec nous je vois
votre question logan vous nous parler du
temps de chargement va écouter on va
déjà abordé la rétrocompatibilité
ensuite on les prendra sur cette
question là bas je m y répondre tout de
suite d'accord
en fait les temps de chargement sont
vraiment très très très très faible sur
la console est en fait ils sont beaucoup
plus faibles
même sur les jeux rétro compatible corps
donc là par exemple on le dit space va
se lancent beaucoup plus rapidement que
des espèces de l'époque la mare aux
songes et pas pouvoir vous montrer avec
red dead redemption parce qu'il nous
faut il me faudrait le disque mais je ne
vais pas sur moi j'ai oublié de le
prendre mais il ya plein plein de jeux
360 en fait les temps de chargement sont
quasiment à nier quoi d'accord c'est
juste parce qu'une bonne une bonne
nouvelle moi j'ai besoin de jouer un jeu
de finir métro exodus et les temps de
chargement sont extrêmement c'est
impressionnant donc c'est bien ça nous
fera avancer un petit peu et ça c'est
quand même une bonne nouvelle pour cette
nouvelle génération
alors merci à vous voilà on essaye en
tout cas de vous répondre en direct
comme pour vous logan
on va vous laisser découvrir là c'est ce
sont des images in game ou d une game
d'accord donc là on va ça va bientôt
être est fini mais c'est juste pour
montrer le tout début du jeu on va
vraiment effets de lumière qui a voilà
qu'avec voilà donc vous voyez comme
c'est beaucoup plus fin ouais vous voyez
comme c'est quand même beaucoup plus
joli que ça ne l'était à l'époque trouvé
une fois à bord vous avez sûrement
beaucoup de temps à rattraper
voilà juste regarder le soleil dans
notre guide tous les effets de lumière
signalé pas du tout net ce qui est
plutôt bien parce que c'est vrai qu'il
ya plein de jeux qui n'ont pas forcément
mal vieilli et qui la grève de
redécouvrir
mais oui et du coup je trouve que c'est
très bien parce que ça redonne une
deuxième jeunesse à tout votre
ludothèque et notamment votre ludothèque
360 ce que les jeux balla ça y est ils
sont compatibles avec les écrans actuels
ils sont beaucoup plus joli on se dit
pas à non mais c'est trop vieux ça fait
mal aux yeux c'est aliasé c'est un peu
moche j'aime pas trop là voilà il ya
quand même un coup de polish qui est
visible qu'il se voit quand même très
très bien et moi voilà personnellement
ça m'a donné envie de me replonger dans
mes yeux je vois ça me donne très envie
aussi c'est peut-être une bonne raison
de l'acheter bonjour à cuire je ne faire
ne pas écorcher votre votre nom
justement ce qui concerne ce passage un
peu amélioré alors être complète
compatibilité décidemment c'est
difficile à dire on a une question
peut-être un peu technique de yoyo de
jeu qui nous demandent si la xbox
appealing des filtres comme par exemple
un fils anisotropique améliorer ça je la
ressortirai ce genre de fuite en fête
commence à fonctionner selon as des
idées de ce que j'ai compris en fait
c'est une sorte c'est une intelligence
artificielle qui gère sa voix ses des
algorithmes hawking qui gère ça et qui
se disent bon bah là il ya une source de
lumière bim bim
on va rajouter du hdr on va rajouter des
jolis effets de lumière par dessus voilà
en fait c'est tout c'est une ia qui gère
ça c'est des algorithmes qui s'occupe de
tout ça et qui parfois c'est pas
toujours heureux des fois voilà il ya
des petits problèmes mais bon il faut
vraiment avoir un oeil ultra vertou pour
voir leurs pouvoirs quels sont les
soucis
alors là ça ça joue peut-être pas trop
mais on vous rappelle que l'on tourne à
25 images par seconde et non en 50 comme
on aurait plus mais malheureusement les
contraintes techniques de la mise en
ligne en direct pour la vidéo nous
oblige un petit peu à être en 25 mai
donc sachez qu'en plus de ça on peut
avoir deux ps pour certains vieux oui
oui pas largement c'est même le gros
attrait de cette console fait quelques
on était à 60 fps potable et bah je peux
vous dire que ça se voie voix et c'est
et c'est franchement extrêmement
appréciable du coup sûr les jeux de
nouvelle génération
là évidemment ça se voit pas forcément
ça se voit pas forcément mais sur les
anciens aussi va se stabiliser le
framerate
voilà donc vous aurez pas forcément du
60 mais vous aurez sur des vieux jeux de
but - du 30 stable dans ce qui fait que
bas des jeux font qu'on est déjà
beaucoup plus agréable à jouer parce que
voilà il n'y a pas le côté saccadé
donc franchement ça ça donne vraiment un
boost et oui comme je disais une seconde
jeunesse à lui le vieux jeux et à des
vieux jeux que vous allez aussi retrouvé
sur le xbox cas de passe en fait on va
aborder s'est battu très bien c'est
parfait
ah non alors avant on va peut-être
prendre une question une question de
nicolas bonsoir nicolas sur youtube
merci d'être avec nous vous le demandez
comment ça fonctionne au niveau du quick
résume à bas on va pouvoir y répondre
alors là je vois justement en effet
conclure et que vous êtes vous venez de
sauter d'un jeu à l'autre
est ce que on peut reprendre lé jeu in
game alors oui alors grosso modo le
quick résume qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est que ça vous permet de passer d'un
jeu à l'autre sans attente en fait ça va
friser ça va mettre en état de stase
votre parti donc pardon vous êtes sûr
assassin vallat et là vous dites ah
merde il ya un live sur twitter qui
m'intéresse par exemple un cigare life
qui m'intéresse je lance l'application
tweetie je regarde mon live figaro et
boum je vais pouvoir repasser à ma
partie d'assassins qui va reprendre
comme si de rien n'était je ne relance
pas le jeu je repasse pas par le tout
début je repasse pas par le menu
principal
tout est
tout est fait donc là par exemple
normalement ça va marcher avec assassin
silence voilà vous voyez qu'outre les
yeux qui s'affiche et donc je vais
reprendre ma partie là où j'avais arrêté
voilà d'accord donc ça peut paraître
extrêmement gadget mais en fait ça n'est
pas de nom ce n'est pas du tout ça ne
l'est absolument pas parce que vous avez
un confort qui est incroyable juste ne
pas avoir relancé les jeux depuis le
début avec les crédits les machins les
trucs et donc ça permet certes certains
diront oui mais moi je joue qu'à un jeu
à la fois donc je m'en fiche mais juste
le côté passé de youtube switch à
reprendre votre partie de votre parti en
cours bah c'est super aprécial toi on
joue on joue à sa séance du bon allez
stop j'arrête parce qu'on va se regarder
une série netflix et bien immédiatement
après vous reprenez votre parti là où
elle s'était arrêtée mois alors on va
répondre à votre question n'hésitez pas
à les poser
julius caesar qui me demande si la
console fait un bruit d'avions de chasse
au décollage banon justement on est
revenues déjà sur sur ce point mais on
le répète avec plaisir c'est que eh bien
cette console est extrêmement
silencieuse
voilà un bon point par rapport à la
génération précédente encore une fois il
va falloir attendre que des jeux qui
vont mettre la console un peu plus dans
ses derniers retranchements et surtout
l'âge aussi de la console voir si ça ne
fait pas faire un peu plus de bruit à
cette xbox série x on va revenir sur la
question du graphisme aussi de logan qui
me dit ça se voit que l'évolution
question graphique on a battu des
records
on a l'impression que c'est du réel
encore là même effet que si c'était un
casque effet réalité virtuelle un truc
dingue
merci de votre votre commentaire je vois
aussi et là on va peut-être rentrer dans
le dur
tiens à leurs avants avant de rentrer
sur la puissance même et la console on à
cette question de drogue bref est ce que
ça ne va pas léguer la gay avec 35
applis en mode freeze ou alors est-ce
que c'est une appli frise mac ça c'est
intéressant quand est ce qu'on va
pouvoir un peu estimé vraiment la
puissance de cette console alors sur le
sur le quick résume par le souci c'est
qu'on ne sait jamais exactement combien
de jeux on peut mettre en état de freeze
donc là par exemple en avant que
commence le live j'avais lancé yakuza
avec le dragon pour le mettre en état de
quick résume et là vous avez peut-être
vu je les lancers en fait ils bien
repris depuis le début pourquoi parce
que entre temps j'ai lancé assassin j'ai
lancé dette space j'ai lancé forza j'ai
lancé d'autres choses donc la console a
dit y est celui là je ne mets plus en
état de jeûne eux le gel plus et voilà
il repart je relance comme un jeu normal
donc là c'est un petit peu dommage parce
qu'on n'a jamais vraiment une idée de
combien de jeux on peut mettre en
parallèle et les tests que j'ai pu faire
bas des fois c2d fois ces trois des fois
c'est 5
ouais donc plus je l ce que du coup sur
coup dans un jeu sans vous prévenir
alors oui sa fonction là on fait
attention mais après les jeux sont
tellement bardé de sauvegarde
automatique que bon j'ai vraiment verra
pas vraiment de mauvaises surprises là
dessus d'accord bah voilà en tout cas de
cette fonctionnalité alors au lieu de
jeu alors je n'arrive pas et le
prévenant yachts bijoux qui nous demande
sur youtube si on stream avec le
logiciel xbox actuelle mais en attendant
on est sur un streaming avec un logiciel
un peu plus un peu plus compétents et un
peu plus fort en termes de technique
grâce à julien tunnel à la réalisation
qui nous permet de faire ce stream à la
fois sur la page principale du figaro
sur youtube mais également sur twitter
donc voilà c'est pas souvent et on le
félicite comme souvent voilà pour cette
question et maintenant et qui vous
remercie on vous salue on a beaucoup de
questions et je pourrai pas citer tous
mais non car c'est une question qui nous
est beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup revenus
que ce soit sur youtube sur la home ou
sur twitter on a une question bah je
vais la prendre puisqu'elle résume assez
bien toutes ces questions qui sont
tombées sur la puissance de la console
les jeux multi plateformes sont ils plus
beau sur xbox series ou sur ps5
et quelles sont la différence aussi de
puissance entre les jeux xbox série xps
ça commence à faire beaucoup de facteurs
on peut peut-être revenir dessus
est ce qu'on peut déjà dresser des
comparatifs entre la xbox et sa
concurrente la p55
franchement y apparemment différence
d'accord
il n'y a pas vraiment de différence de
puissance alors certes il semblerait que
assassin's creed sur pèse 5 soit un
petit peu mieux parce qu'il ya un effet
un effet ce qu'on appelle un effet de
tearing un effet un peu de vague qui à
part un petit peu à l'écran sur
sur la xbox mais sinon en terme de
puissance pure
alors certes il y aura toujours des gens
pour chipoter pas dire oui mais en fait
non voilà mes machin mais on va dire sur
un oeil de consommateur lambda vous
n'avez pas vraiment voir la différence
voire même pas du tout de différence
entre la paix 5 et la xbox série x
franchement vous ne verrez pas et du
coup là dessus j'insiste que vous
choisissiez la paix 5 ou la xbox
vous ferez le bon choix il n'y a pas de
yaba genre alors mais en fait il est le
concert qui est complètement naze et
l'autre qui est vachement mieux ce plus
nintendo nintendo face à ces gars c'est
la différence ça va être le catalogue de
jeu évidemment ça y est les exclusivités
est ce que les exclusivités sony vous
les adorez vous la saison et jouer oui
acheter une ps 5
est ce que vous êtes plutôt sensible aux
exclusivités microsoft et bien prenez
une xbox est aussi ce qui est
intéressant avec la avec tout l'univers
xbox c'est le game pas ce qui pour moi
est vraiment un service exceptionnel
donc le game passe on le rappelle c'est
une sorte de netflix du jeu vidéo qu'on
n'a pas encore trop aborder et qui
justement est assez intéressant c'est ce
que vous voyez très exactement derrière
nous et qui donc eu une sorte de netflix
du jeu vidéo qui permet de jouer à des
jeux
enfin c'est un catalogue de jeux mais
qui ne qui se fait dans le cloud alors
non alors est ce que c'est ça c'est bon
c'est pas dans le cloud c'est pas dans
le club
grosso modo c'est un service
d'abonnement quand il va coûter soit 10
euros par mois pour la version simple
soit 13 euros par mois et cette version
à 13 euros par mois va vous permettre
aussi de jouer en ligne à vos jeux xbox
c'est ridicule c'est la même chose que
le xbox live c'est ça qu'on fait ça
c'est un teg le xbox live la version à
deux euros
vous avez le xbox live avec donc avec
des jeux gratuits également qu'ils sont
fils et chaque mois donc la version à
très heureux comme ultra intéressante et
donc ce service vous permet vous offre
un catalogue d'une centaine de jeux qui
sont très régulièrement mise à jour qui
sont signés par microsoft mais là en
fait depuis cette semaine vous avez
également tout le catalogue ea et qui
vient d'arriver d'accord donc le
catalogue de juillet donc voilà vous
avez
vous avez star wars jedi fall and order
vous avez fifa 20 mai c'est la verse une
version d'essai de 10 heures ensuite
vous devez acheter là vous devez acheter
la version si vous voulez continuer mais
les anciens officiers à fifa 10 9 et
inclut donc aggraver les jeux
nécessitent des jeux qui sont en version
un peu des mots voilà en fait c'est une
des versions cd accès anticipé enfin
même si mal un poteau pour le coup c'est
plus anticipé mais voilà il vous offre
10 heures de jeu sur les nouveautés mais
par contre les gens qui ont plus de six
mois
intègre le nier il eu il plaît et donc
vous avez tous les jeux ben voilà vous
savez même des jeux de la première xbox
d'accord blake donc ça c'est pour le
catalogue ea qui vient qu'il a intégré
alors ces passages pardon nicolas qui
nous pose une question sur youtube est
ce qu'on va faire aussi un live pour la
sortie de la ps -cinq oui bien sûr
est-ce que julien à la réalisation peut
nous dire quand est ce qu'on a prévu de
le faire déjà j'ai oublié jeudi ou
vendredi prochain voilà donc n'hésitez
pas alors trouvez que ce soit sur la
homepage du figaro sur youtube mais
également sur twitch pardon chloé et
donc sur le reste du catalogue donc là
j'ai passé tous les catalogues et donc
vous allez voir c'est extrêmement
variées vous avez du jeu indépendant de
haute qualité comme céleste comme grim
fandango pendant gaulle la version
remastered du très vieux classiques de
pc voilà vous avez un jeu de rôle
japonais tales of vesperia
vous avez une nouveauté un des scores
ringer une nouveauté française qui est
vachement bien vous avez destiny 2 vous
avez attendre je vous mettre le
catalogue complet
voilà meilleur classement donc ce voile
à batman arkam night
vous avez minecraft évidemment si au fil
d'une eternal gear 5 tous les à l'eau
ouais c'est vraiment un catalogue large
et 1 4 voilà mais qui qui couvre aussi
plein de classe par exemple vous lancer
un jeu
mais en fait je peux pas lancer
immédiatement jeu il fallait télécharger
c'est ça et ça serait d'accord ok il
faut les télécharger sur votre console
ok alors on est la bonne question de
norsk n 76 merci sur twitch qui ne
demandent si un jeu auquel je jouais
retiré du catalogue
est-ce que je n'y aurait plus accès est
ce que je peux garder le jeu tant que je
n'ai pas ce pas c'est une très bonne
question pour l'anecdote moi j'ai encore
la demo de pythie le jeu silent hill
acquis dans la démo est sorti qui a fait
un très grand succès mais dans le jeu a
été annulée à la presse moi j'ai encore
cette démo sur mon disque dur je peux
encore y jouer
est ce que ce serait possible avec les
jeux qui sont disponibles sur game passe
alors c'est une très bonne question je
vous avoue que la vue que j'ai le guen
base depuis une semaine j'ai pas pu voir
ça par contre ce qui est très bien c'est
qui vous avertissent quand les jeux vont
sortir du catalogue donc là bas comment
ça s'appelle bientôt abandonner bon dont
la radiation
et voilà bon ils vous disent oui à ces
quatre jeux ils vont bientôt sortir du
catalogue donc si vous voulez jouer si
vous voulez télécharger c'est maintenant
ou jamais assez surprenants comme le
fait de retirer d'automne aux principle
passé récent et plutôt bien d'ailleurs
trois cdc des choses qui sont dit les
avec les éditeurs voilà donc ces genres
bon ben ok je te mets pendant trois mois
six mois un an mon jeu sur ton catalogue
et ensuite je le retire pour qu'ils
puissent intégrer à notre catalogue vous
ou pas donc il faut quand même
surveiller l'emprunt le bientôt
abandonner pour voilà savoir qu'est-ce
qu'il faut télécharger qu'est-ce qu'il
faut jouer très très vite
mais en tout cas vous allez c'est un
catalogue de très haute qualité et vous
allez vraiment trouvé de quoi jouer
d'autant que et ça aussi c'est important
toutes les créations tous les jeux faits
par les studios de microsoft
ils sont nombreux parce qu'ils sont
maintenant 23 intègre le guen passe dès
le jour de leur sortie donc donc le
prochain halo il sera dans le guen passe
ok c'est intéressant en tout cas ça va
on en parlait déjà ça fait des années
qu'on fait des lives jeu vidéo vaccaro
ça fait des années qu'on parle d'eux
l'aneth netflix isation du jeu vidéo est
ce que là selon vous c'est un vrai pas
qu'ils aient passé avec cet abonnement
qui est relativement pas cher c'est quoi
c'est le prix d'un netflix mais pour
jouer c'est un catalogue de jeux vidéo
s'est fixé le prix d'un fx alors certes
les gens qui n'ont pas la fibre
bon c'est sûr que c'est un peu moins
souple pour eux parce que ben voilà vous
avez pas voir vous avez pas télécharger
votre jeu en
5 minutes 10 minutes 20 minutes ça a
plutôt se compter en heures sauf pour
vraiment les tout petits jeux dont parle
en milliards j'ai téléchargé final
fantasy 8 rima store qui pèse 2 giga
pour que ça pour ça monte ça a été très
vite emballé c'est pesé malgré ma
connexion adsl alors que par exemple si
je télécharge jada il faut dès lors
order je sais que j'en ai pour plusieurs
heures sur ma connexion adsl alors si
vous avez la fibre bon c'est pas un
souci donc ça c'est juste la petite
friction si vous n'avez pas si vous
n'avez pas voilà une très bonne
connexion et si vous avez vraiment un
petit adsl juste vous oubliez le guen
passe vous faites une croix dessus c'est
même pas la peine parce que vous allez
perdre beaucoup trop de temps dans les
téléchargements ça va être infernal soit
là mais tous vos téléchargements la nuit
et pendant la journée pour vous
travaillez vous êtes à l'école mais bon
ça va pas être une expérience très
satisfaisante si vous êtes n'avait pas
une très bonne connexion internet mais
on en parlait avant ce live c'était une
des choses qui avaient fait des phrases
qui avant le lancement de la xbox
précédente c'était le fait que si on
avait pas internet
donc pour certains certains foyers par
exemple vous pouvez pas carrément jeux à
la console et je me suis même de cette
réponse du du dg de la boîte qui disait
de toute façon si on avait pas internet
on vous conseille d'acheter la 360 ce
qu'avait fait des phrases qui est assez
impressionnant pour ella à l'envers
c'est plus le cas alors ces phrases que
là en fait c'était sur la première
version qui a été présentée à l'e3 du
coup 2013 coup de vieux coup de vieux et
vu le tollé que ça a fait microsoft est
revenu en arrière ils ont dit non au
chaos qui ont fait pas une console 100%
en ligne
on abandonne vous pouvez jouer offline
n'y a pas de souci bon bah je vous
annonce que vous pouvez toujours jouer
offline parce que là quand on a fait les
réglages ben on n'était pas du tout
connecté à internet et les jeux se
lancer absolument sans soucis donc le
gamepad va pas vous va pas vous demander
d'être absolument connecter à internet
pour valider les jeux sont sur votre
votre disque dur donc ça vous pouvez
quand même vous pouvez quand même y
accéder et même vos jeux classiques
voilà c'est pas besoin d'être là d'avoir
une connexion permanente
sauf sur certains jeux par exemple
assassin's creed vous demande d'être
connecté d'accord parce que j'ai eu un
problème bien vous avez peut-être vu
mardi pour la sortie de la xbox le xbox
live à cracher pendant une heure et moi
je voulais jouer assassins et je pouvais
pas j'étais coincé à l'écran d'accueil
parce qu'il fallait que je me connecte
sur mon compte xbox live pour lancer le
jeu
eh ben je pouvais pas parce qu'elles
viennent pas de mondial donc voilà
pendant une heure j'ai pas pu jauger
d'accord bon bah voilà on est on est
prévenu en tout cas on va rester sur la
question du multijoueur et de la
connexion internet pour thomas elisabeth
sur youtube qui nous demande qui
reconnaît ne pas s'y connaître bien en
xbox aînés qui nous demande concernant
le multijoueur est ce que je peux
accéder et jouer facilement avec la
communauté d'un jeu y at il un système
de discussion vocale simplifiée alors je
dois dire moi qui suis un ancien joueur
de xbox 360 et donc de xbox live moi je
vais beaucoup au premier gears of war le
j'ai toujours trouvé le système multi
joueurs du xbox live un peu plus
performants et ergonomiques
ouais que celui de l'apple store alors
moi je ne suis pas en ligne dont le
groupe attend cette question bah écoutez
je pourrais pas je pourrai pas vous
répondre moi qui n'ai pas testé la
console en tout cas mais sachez qu
historiquement le xbox live déjà et je
crois même pour les consoles c'était le
premier système et le multi qui était
sortie sur la première xbox donc ça déjà
pas mal d'expérience un peu plus que la
playstation est quand même un système un
peu plus simplifié que sur playstation
donc voila mais là c'est vraiment que de
la queue de la voilà de comment on
pourrait dire ça alors voilà je peux que
estimé c'est que de l'estimation de dos
tout ça voilà on est une question de
logan qui nous pose une question qui est
intéressante je sais pas si c'est
possible ça ça doit dépendre des
plateformes en question qui nous demande
s'il est possible de mettre par exemple
de lancer un jeu et de lancer une
application en fond comme par exemple
youtube pour écouter de la musique c'est
intéressant ça c'est pas possible
voilà on a aussi d'autres questions
j'essaie de vous lire bonjour stéphane
vous le demande et si les jeux steam
sont supportés ça dépend si le jeu est
une exclusivité steam ou si le jeu est
disponible à la fois sur différentes
plateformes
c'est le cas par exemple de certains
jeux pc que l'on trouvera pas sur sur
les consoles mais voilà ça encore une
fois c'est du c'est du cas par cas
tiens une très bonne question divers 9
qui nous demande sur youtube si le cross
plateforme sera dispo à priori oui
à priori oui parce que c'est vraiment
c'est un des chevaux de bataille de
microsoft c'est tout ce qui est grosse
plaie tout ce qui est trois générations
c'est de faire en sorte que voilà qu on
abaisse les barrières entre les consoles
et que tout le monde puisse jouer
ensemble après il faut qu'on fasse
nintendo et sony soit d'accord ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas
mais pardon ils ont réussi autour de
minecraft qu'ils ont réussi le tour de
force night aussi rock est lui aussi
sorti cet été
alors j'essaye de vous suivre n'hésitez
pas je le répète à poser toutes vos
questions on est en direct sur la page
principale du figaro sur youtube sur
twitch alors que je joue derrière nous
le dernier yakuza qui vient tout juste
de sortir
mais voilà en tout cas qui répond à
votre question hivernaux et je vais
essayer de vous suivre sur la page
principale du figaro également je ne
faisais pas encore saluer bonjour deux
points chris karim ou encore mind style
qui étaient avec nous
vous le demandiez des infos sur les sur
les exclusivités qui valent le coup pour
se pencher vers la xbox series bon on
est revenues des gens d'église rêve et
on peut il revenir encore balance aussi
pour cette sortie pour à cette sortie il
n'y a pas d'exclusivité
voilà c'est clair et net il en a pas
pour la bonne raison que halo a été
retardé à cause du coc vide parce que
les équipes de développement n'ont pas
pu finir à temps parce que comme vous le
savez le travail à distance c'est pas
facile c'est pas facile non plus contre
une équipe de jeux vidéo de travailler à
distance donc voilà le jeu était pas
satisfaisante pour sortir en l'état donc
il retardé de plusieurs mois dans ce
qu'il est que hélas voilà il n'y a pas
de ya pas de sortie exclusive sur cette
console au lancement mais c'est pas
grave parce que les exclusivités arrive
un peu tard voilà en tout cas pour vous
répondre sur la page principale du
figaro n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions je vais vous échangez c'est ça
fait plaisir
et ce sont de très bons commentaires
merci à vous bah pour se répéter aussi
un peu mais je pense que c'est
intéressant de le répéter plusieurs fois
chris karine qui nous demandent quels
avantages il y a un rapport à la xbox
par rapport à la ps1 kva comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure il n'y en a pas il
ya c'est à vous de faire le choix car
par rapport à la rs oui par rapport à
peine 5 bah ouais quand tu disais tout à
l'heure si on n'a pas vraiment fins et
des consoles qui sont quand même très
similaires techniquement la différence
ça va être évidemment les exclusivités
donc ça va dépendre de vos goûts
également le
le guen parce qu'il n'ya pas sur
playstation sont postés femmes et le
playstation nord mais le playstation
home
alors lui qui fonctionne à la fois et en
streaming et en téléchargement mais
globalement je clos catalogue est moins
bon dans le catalogue est moins bon
parce qu'il est moins frais il ya moins
de vraiment de nouveautés la sony essaie
de travailler là dessus en mettant des
f1 en mettant des gros jeux mais qui
resteront que pendant un mois ou deux
par exemple où il ya eu gta5 abandonner
c'était pendant deux mois
lancement il ya des secondes il va
rester jusqu'en janvier je crois et une
fois qu'ils sont partis sont partir vous
pouvez plus y rejouer même s'ils sont
sur votre disque dur c'est terminé ouais
donc va moi je trouve le catalogue du ps
nord est moins intéressant que celui du
kansas bon bah voilà qui vous répond
bonsoir à vous sur youtube
rabhi thomas qui demande si ça va bien
ça va très bien et vous dites le nous
dans le tchat sur youtube ce serait
qu'un gérant plaisir que nous vous
livrons j'ai un petit peu chaud parce
que je suis à côté de la xbox 360 degrés
donc en tout cas voilà ça brille mais
l'on fera des économies d'énergie coupez
vos radiateurs cet hiver en plein de
confinement second du nom voilà alors je
vais je vais répondre à votre question
on a amis de l'auteur qui s'énerve parce
qu'on prend pas ces questions parce
qu'on essaye d'être exhaustif de
répondre à toutes les questions dont il
faut être patient à vide mais ça y est
on vous prend vous nous demandez s'il y
aura du sang la fps et où est ce que
l'on s'est procurées la constable a
recommencé procurer la console passé
microsoft fournit la donne et voilà
qui a donné une console au figaro pour
qu'on puisse faire des tests et qu'on
puisse l'essayer qu'on puisse faire ce
live et sinon sur 120 fps wii alors ça
c'est les promesses de ces nouvelles
consoles c'est de monter jusqu'à 120 fps
donc pas tout de suite plus tard dans
quelques années mais en tout cas voilà
vous avez aussi fourni avec la console
un câble spécifique un câble hdmi 2.1
d'accord donc vraiment il ya très peu de
co2 de télévision qui sont compatibles
avec le 2.1 mais il permettra dans les
années à venir c'est pour sa garde et le
précieusement de profiter du 120 f s
alors justement stephen nous demande si
la ps1 qu elle est rétrocompatible vous
ne l'expliqué impartialement vata néo
rétro compatible qu'avec les jeux ps4
vous ne pouvez pas jouer à vos jeux à
vos vieux jeux ps1 ps2 ps3 et c'est bien
dommage parce que personnellement j'en
ai une pelletée c'est vrai mais n'ont
donc il ya que les jeux ps4 auquel vous
pouvez rejouer est pareil qui s insèrent
vous pouvez soit vous les avez
téléchargés et lus
du coup c'est via le psn savall est
chargé soit vous les avez en version 10
quitte donc il faudra les mettre dans
votre ps 5 et tout coup surtout pas la
version digitale à la version avec les
lecteurs de disques et lassés par contre
ça va un seul est directement depuis le
disque le jeu sur le disque dur donc
c'est une opération qui prend cinq
minutes à peine
on va merci en tout cas à vide pour ces
questions bonsoir à vous de jeunes lopez
cerron soir les ni cool qui étaient avec
nous en début de cela et ben voilà en
tout cas on a pu déjà fait un tour assez
complet de ceux de ce panel que propose
la xbox series x que que l'on a
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas la sas on vous
le rappelle est un peu moins gros sel et
sans lecteur blu ray sans affichage
quatre cas mais elle coûte beaucoup
moins cher avec 300 euros c'est un prix
assez compétitif quand on se souvient de
ses sorties des anciennes consoles
nouvelle génération
ah bah oui c'est explorer à vous avez vu
on avait du coup une crise humain
donc la partie s'est lancé immédiatement
en passant de yakuza assassins et donc
oui oui bah c'est extrêmement compétitif
comme comme pris la ps4 à sa sortie
était à 400 euros la xbox one à sa
sortie était était à 500 euros
la ps3 était à 600 euros en fait même la
switch était à 350 euros
sa sortie donc oui 300 euros pour une
console next gen c'est extrêmement
intéressant même si on le répète elle
n'est pas aussi puissante que la s et
voilà c'est fait attention ne commandait
pas des jeux ont matérialisé vous allez
avoir une très mauvaise surprise oui
parce que vous prenez disque alors c'est
une version c'est une console digital
forcément ça ça passe pas il n'y a pas
de n'y a pas d'endroit pour rentrer le
disque alors on à cette question à ce
commentaire de logan qui nous dit
j'espère que l'on peut choisir qu'on
peut choisir si on peut choisir si on
veut jouer
alors répétez autre question s'il vous
plaît logan j'ai pas trop compris voient
l'année jadis nous ce que vous vouliez
nous poser on comprendra un petit peu
mieux on a une question de julien à la
réalisation aussi à une demande s'il est
possible d'acheter la xbox one avec un
abonnement mensuel c'est vrai que ça ça
fonctionnait âge l'ancien à l'époque de
la 360 fallait acheter des soit un
abonnement mensuel soit des abonnements
annuels commencer à baisser sur ça
c'était pour le live où elle est là je
viens tu te demandes si on peut acheter
la xbox série x à crédit oui vous pouvez
en fait il ya une offre dont qui pour le
moment n'est commercialisé que par
micromania qui vous permet d'avoir la
xbox série x plus le game passe à 13
euros c'est à celui qui à 13 euros par
mois dont peu gamepad qui contient aussi
le xbox live donc ils vous parleront
grosso modo d'avoir tout de joie en
ligne d'avoir les jeux du game passe etc
etc pour 33 euros par mois d'accord
pendant deux ans donc ça vous engage
pendant deux ans donc vous êtes obligés
de payer pendant deux ans c'est un peu
comme quand vous achetez un téléphone
portable et que pour vous lycée pendant
deux ans l'achat de votre téléphone avec
votre forfait avec votre forfait
téléphonique voilà c'est la même chose
dont vous avez la console plus le guen
passe pendant deux ans à 33 euros par
mois mais pour le moment donc il ya
seulement microsoft
micromania pardon le propose la fnac
devait faire aussi mais là avec la
fermeture des magasins ils ont estimé
que c'était un petit peu trop compliqué
parce que ça reste un crédit certains
crédits à taux zéro mais un crédit quand
même donc il faut il faut examiner vos
capacités d'emprunt il faut voir quels
sont votre solvabilité
donc il ya des documents à fournir et on
vous donc micromania fait ça en ligne
mais qui n'a que préfère faire ça de
visu voilà que vous rencontriez un
conseiller etc pour voir si votre
situation financière permet de
contracter ce prêt pendant deux ans et
mais si c'est le cas ça vous permet
quand même de lycée l'achat de la
console qui est quand même à 500 euros
et en plus des près les calculs qui ont
été faits vous gagnez même de l'argent
en fait en passant par le donc ça
s'appelle le all access et ça vous
permet je crois que vous économisez au
total quasiment 50 euros au bout des
deux ans entre l'achat de la console
plus le gamepad voilà vous avez comme
une ristourne à la fin qui est assez
intéressante alors je suis en train de
faire une petite recherche pour vous
répondre
je crois que c'est sûr
youtube de jules césar qui nous demande
si on a des nouvelles concernant les
stocks de la console en france est bas
alors c'est un peu compliqué en cette
période là là c'est très compliqué alors
c'est extrêmement compliqué sur les
stocks d'accord grosso modo la règle
générale c'est si vous ne l'avez pas
commander si vous ne l'avez pas
précommandé donc les précommandes
avaient ouvert en septembre
c'est pas une quête impossible mais
c'est une quête qui s'annonce
extrêmement compliqué si vous voulez
absolument une console pour noël
d'accord pourquoi parce que les stocks
sont limités à cause du coc vide on n'a
pas les consoliers ont pas pu être à
pleine capacité pour fabriquer les
consoles d'accord donc les stocks voilà
sont pas immenses et les stocks qui
étaient alloués pour la xbox série x
pour sa sortie en france ont été vendus
en quelques heures
donc c'était lors des précommandes de
septembre en quelques heures tout est
parti voilà donc au final la demande
quand même est forte
et oui c'est pas évident même si on a
j'ai posé la question à microsoft
il va y avoir du réassort donc c'est
aussi à vous de surveiller de surveiller
sur le site de la fnac sur le site de
micromania de carrefour de leclerc de
auchan de tout ce que vous voulez voilà
pouvait faudra vérifier quasiment tous
les jours s'il n'ya pas voilà le mobile
c'est pas du stock de disponible parce
que bon on le rappelle pour le moment
avec le confinement tous les rayons jeux
vidéo sont fermés n'importe où que vous
alliez à carrefours au gosier à
micromania micromania est fermé c'est
uniquement pour le click and collect
carrefour vous pouvez aller faire vos
courses mais vous pouvez pas accéder au
rayon jeux vidéo
pareil pour leclerc pareil pour auchan
pareil pour toutes les marques
intermarché et c'est donc ça ne sert
strictement à rien d'aller en magasin
tant que les règles du confinement n'ont
pas été levés d'accord
donc tout ça se passe en ligne donc
voilà c'est à vous de surveiller je vous
vous dis ça va pas être évident mais les
miracles existent
j'ai un ami qui par exemple n'avait pas
commandé à temps il a réussi quand même
il a eu un moment donné à ben sûr je ne
sais plus quel site il on est un petit
peu de stock
il a commandé vendredi dernier du coup
il a pu la récupérer leur miracle des
lancements cdti miracle donc faut pas
perdre espoir
il ya certes un compte twitter qui sont
assez spécialiste là dessus pour repérer
par exemple hamster joueurs amateurs sur
twitter voilà pour repérer un peu ce
type de réassort donc que ce soit pareil
des erreurs de prix ou à grosse promo
sassou intéressant donc soyez
franchement réactif mais ce sera
évidemment beaucoup plus simple à partir
de 2021 si vous voulez absolument une
console alors justement pour pour vous
répondre précisément je viens d'aller me
balader sur à la fois la fnac amazon
boulanger rakuten darty auchan carrefour
sachez que sur les sites de carrefour et
auchan la console n'est même pas proposé
que sur boulanger la console est
indisponible et que méfiez-vous des faux
surprises et des fausses joies
alors là c'est un réfrigérateur et ne
ressemblent beaucoup c'est pour ça que
je me suis fait avoir mais chez vous des
vendeurs tiers jambes notamment sur
amazon qui vont vous proposer dire oui
ok on a une xbox mais ils vont là vous
vous la vendre 800 euros ouais ouais
c'est que si certains prix là par
exemple si on va sur sur un coup tu es
nous vous en avez une comme 9 750 euros
je ne suis pas sûr que je me laisserai
tenter vous avez aussi déjà des
occasions méfiez-vous peut-être il vaut
peut-être mieux attendre un petit peu
voilà mais en tout cas sachez qu'après
sur les plateformes en ligne comme la
fnac com rakuten comme comme amazon bah
là voilà on voit que c'est déjà tout de
suite plus compliqué pour se faire
livrer donc vérifiez bien avant
d'acheter et soyez très prudents là
dessus n'achetez pas n'importe quel prix
voilà non vraiment c'est pas parce que
voilà il ya quelqu'un qui va un vendeur
tirs sur amazon qui va vous dire oui je
vous la fais à 700 800 900 euros
ça vaut pas la peine ça vaut pas la
peine de payer le double de son prix une
console surtout vous attendez dans
quelques semaines en janvier vous vous
l'aurez quoi mais comme nous le dit dror
bref méfiez-vous des réfrigérateurs car
oui quoi vous avez tout à fait raison
mais vraiment je me suis fait vous voyez
je me suis fait duper si on peut
peut-être revoir j'ai eu un tunnel à
réaliser ce beau réfrigérateurs qui ne
servent à stocker nos jeux vidéo ce sera
un beau truc et à l'inversé d'un
réfrigérateur celle-ci chauffe beaucoup
beaucoup plus sain oui oui ça choque pas
je vous dis moi j'ai bien choisi la
console juste à côté
par contre elle ne fait pas de bruit
voilà et ça c'est vraiment
impressionnant
voilà pour cela je vous tenez on a une
question de driss ben bella qui nous
demandent si on sent que le gameplay
plus fluide sur next gen que sur ps4
est-ce que cela change quelque chose à
tuer oui et pourtant dieu sait que les
jeux qui arrivent sur les nouvelles
consoles généralement à l'entrée de
nouvelle génération le gap est pas
forcément
ouf
la cie franchement je vois la différence
le jeu voilà évidemment vous avez pas
vous rendre compte parce que pour des
questions techniques on peut pas
diffuser en 60 fps mais là le jeu est en
60 fps tout est extrêmement fluide tout
est extrêmement détaillé l'âge et des
effets de lumière absolument incroyable
et j'ai vu assassins en version
ps4 c'est quand même vachement mont-joli
quoi donc
donc oui on sent vraiment l'apport
next-gen et je vous conseille la semaine
prochaine quand nous ferons le live ps5
le jeu spider man en fait vous permet de
choisir entre un mode qui va plutôt
privilégier le 60 fps ou un mode sli a
plutôt privilégié tout ce qui est
rétrécie hng donc pour faire simple le
racing c'est un effet magique qui va
faire que quand vous croisez une flaque
d'eau l'environnement autour de vous se
refait dans la flaque d'eau ce qu'ils
ont ça c'est l'exemple un peu basique de
ce que peut faire le ray tracing mais au
lieu d'avoir juste genre un peu de
lumière sur la flaque d'eau vous allez
voir l'arbre qui à côté
l'immeuble qu'ils en fassent la lumière
qui vient des néons autour de vous qui
va se refléter dans cette dans cette fac
d'accord il a on verra vraiment une
belle démonstration de ce que les deux
modes apporte je trouve que c'est assez
clair quand on verra ça la semaine
prochaine à la même heure jeudi au
vendredi ouais voilà on va voir quand
est ce qu'on l'a fait précisément mais
mais c'est l'idée mais oui on voit la
différence
on a des questions divers nov toujours
sur youtube qui nous demande quand
est-ce que les jeux photos réalistes
non ça c'est nico quand est-ce que je
photoréaliste sortiront bas il va
falloir attendre un peu pour en tout cas
ce qui des deux du photo réalisme c'est
pas pour tout de suite mais 2021 et
promet d'être riche
voilà hiver neufs qui ne demandent quels
types d'écrans tv il vaut mieux
l'exploiter au maximum pour la console
très bonne question à c'est une
excellente question alors dans un monde
idéal où vous avez un portefeuille
illimitée dans ce monde idéal vous allez
plutôt choisir le top du top donc c'est
à dire une télé 4k une télé oled une
télé qui peut monter jusqu'à 120 fps et
une télé qui va être équipée du coup
deux ports hdmi 2.20 là normalement vous
serez pas mal par contre bas votre votre
porte votre banquier risque de faire un
peu la tête parce que c'est des télés
qui coûte largement plus de 1000 euros
on est plutôt sur du 1500 voire plus
l'écran va être grand voilà vous pouvez
monter à du tour a mis 4 me
voilà donc c'est vraiment un
investissement donc il doit vous n'êtes
pas obligé de payer aussi cher mais
grosso modo si vous voulez vraiment
avoir une télé qui va exploiter la
puissance de la next-gen
grosso modo c'est vraiment de la bonne
qualité il faut compter en moyenne 1000
euros ce qui est un investissement vous
allez pouvoir aussi trouver des modèles
qui seront pas mal mais pas évidemment
aussi bien que ce soit 1000 qui seront
plutôt à 500 600 700 euros
la question qui arrivera après qu'ils
aient oui mais j'ai pas de télé 4k est
ce que ça vaut le coup du coup d'acheter
une console next-gen
sachant que je ne pas pouvoir profiter
de tous ces petits ajouts alors il se
trouve que chez moi je n'ai pas de télé
4 kg une télé 1080p qui a plusieurs
années derrière elle mais qui est qui
est vraiment performante les l'image est
vraiment très très jolie mal gré mal gré
les âges et oui alors certes j'ai pas le
hdr dessus certes j'ai pas la 4k dessus
mais je vois la différence
je vois vraiment la différence par
rapport à des jeux ps4 je vois la
fluidité quand on est en mode 60 fps
donc j'en profite même si j'ai pas une
télé ultramoderne ma télé je les ai
achetés en 2010 voilà pour être voilà
dix ans derrière elle mais c'est une
télé qui va qui marche c'est une
sanction qui va extrêmement bien et
voilà en fait ça m'embête un peu de la
changer parce qu'elle fonctionne bien
sûr elle fonctionne très bien et rien
que je sais que ce serait vachement plus
mieux avec une telle ées une telle ées à
1000 euros
évidemment mais voilà c'est pas parce
que vous avez une télé ancien une télé
1080p que vous allez vous allez y perdre
je vous prends un exemple
vous souvenez quand on a fait le saut
entre la ps2 et la ps3 mais quand vous
aviez une télévision cathodique
c'était juste l'horreur jouer sur ps3 ou
sur xbox 360 sur une télévision
cathodique
pourquoi parce que il y avait plein de
textes qui était strictement illisibles
sur cathodique les texans vote était de
plus en plus petit de plus en plus fins
la catholique ne gérait pas ça du tout
et je me souviens que quand j'ai acheté
ma xbox 360 quand je jouais à gta iv ou
à red dead redemption premier du nom je
ne voyais pas les sous titres je ne
pouvais pas les lire c'était impossible
mais c'est vrai c'est un peu trop petit
donc ce qui fait que on profitait pas du
tout est là pour le coup j'ai ramon mis
de côté ma console je me dis bon en fait
c'était le moment où j'étais tu leur
entrée dans la vie active
j j'attends mon premier salaire et je
m'achète une télé je m'achète une télé
hd
on n'est pas du tout dans ce cas de
figure aujourd'hui bien sûr donc
vraiment pas vous avez pas dire bon
allez je le mette je mets ma télé à la
poubelle et j'en achète une nouvelle
vous pouvez le faire évidemment mais
vous n'êtes pas obligé pour profiter de
votre console
c'est toute cette évolution
technologique qu'on peut observer que ce
soit pour les télévisions pour les jeux
eux-mêmes on voit quand même que le gap
de génération est beaucoup moins
flagrant contre une ps2 et une ps3 c'est
assez impressionnant et à vous voyez la
distance d'affichage la panne aura ma
ouais on voit l'église tout là haut on à
une époque on voyait ça dans les trailer
de witcher 3 mais c'était assez
exceptionnel qu'on voit la montagne tout
là-haut voilà le note si sommet sur
lequel on pourra certainement aller
enfin vous voyez c'est quand même une
distance d'affichage absolument dingue
alors que sur les consoles actuelles
vous aurez peut-être là on verra pas
aura peut-être un petit flou alors on va
revenir sur quelques questions un peu
décalé qu'on reçoit que ce soit sur
youtube par exemple avec lui aux jo qui
nous demande est là rtx 3090 en
parle-t-on va écouter non environ 1800
60 euros la carte graphique pour jouer
sur pc on va se contenter d'une xbox
série s à 300 euros ce sera très bien
non mais là on est sur d'autres sphères
alors moi j'ai un autre copain qui a
investi justement sur une perte x
donc il a dépensé un fric fou pour sa
carte sa carte graphique
il a aussi acheté une télévision oled
qui coûte une fortune
et oui assassin est absolument
magnifique 1 c'est un verseau
c'est vrai que même un massage à ce prix
là mais bon voilà c'est toi qu'au total
il investit quasiment 4 à 5000 euros
donc à nos amis des bêtes
tiens on a on a un bon commentaire c'est
décalé de gilles de six heures qui nous
dit qu'en parlant de réfrigérateur 1
tout à l'heure je me suis trompé en
cherchant dans l'est dans les services
de vente par internet et je suis tombé
sur un frigo tellement la console
ressemble un frigo et c'est vrai que
jesse zanon rappelle que xbox en afrique
fabriquer un est-ce que je viens qu'une
elle peut basculer sur mon écran on a
cette console je trouve que c'est
vraiment décalé et que ça montre
vraiment que le le comparatif est assez
assez flagrant voyez la taille de la
bête
ce n'est pas une console c'est bel et
bien un frigo et un frigo à l'image de
la recherche de la laine sol c'est
vraiment des cadres aux je sais pas qui
pourra se payer cette édition limitée
mais mais voilà en tout cas je sais pas
si haut si elle prend les blu ray mais
on verra ça sur un prochain test sur
twitch voilà en tout cas merci de jeu
césar j'avais ça que j'avais oublié
cette sortie que j'avais vu passer dans
la semaine
alors on va reprendre la question de
logan qui nous avait posé une question
tout à l'heure qu'on n'avait pas réussi
à prendre et ce que l'on peut choisir
les styles de réseau en cross platform
dans les menus d'options que ça soit pc
uniquement xbox ou ps c'est vrai que
quand on joue en ligne souvent le fait
d'être soumis à plusieurs communautés
qui vont avoir potentiellement une
souris ou certaines tendances de jeu ça
peut être compliqué est ce qu on a déjà
des idées là-dessus je ne saurais pas
répondre à cette question
désolé lagarde désolé alors tiens très
bonne question de dead style sur twitch
finalement si on garde les succès et les
sauvegardes de la xbox one finalement
c'est quoi c'est un gamertag qu'on
conserve c'est certain qu'on a depuis
les rues 160 quoi oui alors vous
conservez tous alors notamment si vous
étiez abonnés xbox live en fait tout est
parti dans le club
donc vous conservez vos succès moi j'ai
retrouvé du coup mes points mais mes
vieux points xbox qui elles sont
absolument ridicules
donc vous conservez tous vous conservez
votre succès vous toutes ces choses là
et les sauvegardes aussi si elles ont
été mises en le club et sinon bon ben il
ya toute une procédure de transfert par
clé usb ou par directement par wifi pour
transférer les données de votre console
vers la console actuelle
donc c'est assez chaud alors jours
j'anticipe aussi une question de la
semaine prochaine c'est pareil sur ps5
d'accord c'est une opération que j'ai
fait il ya quelques jours voyage et
transférer les données de ma ps4 vers la
paix s 5 c'est plutôt simple à faire ça
prend en fonction de ce qu'il ya sur
votre console ça prend à peu près une
heure mais au moins voyager tous les
jeux ps4 que j'avais en cours j'ai pu
récupérer les sauvegardes parce que moi
je n'ai pas le ps plus donc j'ai pas
aimé sauvegarde dans le club
et donc voilà manuellement boum j'ai mis
mes sauvegardes directement 5 donc j'ai
rien perdu et donc je peux rejouer à
gosses tsushima oui quant à tous
ensemble vers le temple grâce à ce
schéma qui est acquis a reçu un patch
qui la met lire à un doigt jogia pareil
vous avez quatre cas 60 fps sur gossau
tsushima et donc je n'ai pas perdu ma
progression très bon soir contrairement
à quand je suis venu au figaro live oui
c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il ya pas qu il
avait face à lui il ya eu arrêt
n'effaceront de sauvegarde
merci je les remercie on a alors des
questions aux leaders ça ça m'intéresse
pas mal puisque c'est ce que je faisais
avec la xbox 360 est ce qu'on peut
brancher un disque dur externe n'importe
lequel pour stocker des jeux récents il
faut être un petit peu dépendant du
matériel microsoft à vous pouvez le
faire vous pouvez mettre un disque dur
externe par contre il va servir vraiment
de stockage
il vous pourrez pas lire les jeux depuis
ce disque dur bon d'accord ça vous
permet en fait par l'amba d'éviter
d'effacer vos jeux et de les re
télécharger notamment si vous avez une
petite connexion ce qui peut être un
petit peu dérangeant mais voilà c'est
juste
ensuite ce sera à vous de manuellement
groupe basculer de vos jeux de ce disque
dur vers celui de vers le ssd de la
console est ce que tu es bon alors qu'un
téléchargement qui vous restent beaucoup
moins loquace note ben voilà pour vous
pour vous répondre
avec vous échangiez là dessus sur
youtube notamment voilà alors on va
bientôt arriver à la fin de ce live si
vous avez des questions à la volée
n'hésitez pas on va en prendre une
dernière stéphane qui me demande s'il
est sur youtube si les manettes xbox 360
sont supportés je ne pense pas non non
non alors les la girafe et répressive
l'algérie avait vérifié peut-être sur
les jeux 360 on peut jouer avec la
manette 360 ça s'est avéré c'est ce que
ça je vous avoue j'ai pas fais le test
pour voir si ça marchait alors vous
posez une colle puisque je me suis pas
renseigné depuis longtemps mais je ne
crois pas oui en effet vous nous
demandez droff ref sur twitch si on a
des nouvelles de dial dans ce crunch 6
bat pour nos enfants c'est comme vous le
rappeler c'est que bethesda a été
racheté par microsoft maintenant à
savoir si ce sera bel et bien une
exclusivité comme c'était le cas pour
les anciens d'or scrolls à l'époque de
leur sortie sur xbox 360 par exemple
pour oblivion et skyrim je crois que
c'était que sur xbox a non non ils sont
sortis sur ps3 en même temps ah oui
d'accord sinon ils sont sortis en même
temps dont karim sûr il est sorti en
même temps ok il est sorti en même temps
donc là ouais elder scroll 6 alors on
sait qu'ils en développement on l'a
enfin on avait juste vu une image halo 3
il ya deux ans et depuis rien
mais
bon voilà on savait que ça allait
prendre un peu de temps donc soyez
patient mais en tout cas le jeu et on
est tenté en développement tiens une
question qui nous qui nous étaient
parvenues tout à l'heure que j'ai oublié
de prendre de thomas elizabeth qui nous
demandent si les je commandais au canada
japon us sont compatibles sur une
console européenne
est-ce que ça c'est toujours d'actualité
c'est une question très précise et
j'imagine que oui mais bon là je prend
normalement ouais ça marchait déjà sur
la 360 je vois pas de raison oui ils
voient pas de raisons mais franchement
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas voilà on a
une question divers 9
beaucoup de questions du ver 9 ce soir
qui me demande si on a une technologie
simuler similaire oreilles tracing sur
xbox wii wheel du ray tracing vous en
aurez partout où vous allez en bouffer
du ray tracing je vous je vous préviens
y en a il y en aura sur toutes les
consoles next-gen
elle gère tout elle gère tout ça donc
vous inquiétez pas après c'est pas
forcément tous les jeux qui vont
exploiter le ray tracing mais en tout
cas ils en sont capables
voilà alors je vais essayer de
bad rester avec vous alors voilà sur la
sur la page principale du figaro bonsoir
à chris krause qui nous a rejoint merci
à vous je vois pas mal de commentaires
merci à vous je vois des questions
notamment de christophe qui nous dit
qu'elles sont là plutôt grosse bah oui
on est sur du 30 cm sur 15 avec 4,5
kilos donc c'est un beau bébé ont
décidément voilà merci la paix 5 et pire
c'est vrai oui la ps1 qui est beaucoup
plus grande elle apaise 5
elle fait 39 cm à webdo j'imaginais pour
ça pour ajouter 10 cm de plus en a les
mois les moins pour qu'on vous la voulez
bcl fait 10 cm de profondeur et
et l'autre je crois qu'on monte à du
vent enfin c'est un paquebot
elle est vraiment immense et donc moins
chez moi d'un c'est dans un meuble télé
est juste en dessous il ya la ps4 et la
ps4
en comparaison il était quand même
bosser et ouais mais va mais c'est rien
par rapport à ce et un orc
c'est un orc elle est vraiment immense
donc vous prévoyez d'aplats chez vous
alors ça c'est quelque chose qui m'avait
un petit peu déçu pour la paix s 5
qu'en est il des casques de réalité
virtuelle est ce qu'il y en a qui sont
proposés sur xbox non non non non il n'y
a pas de ya pas de verre sur sur xbox et
je vous préviens sur ps playstation 5
il y en aura pas avant un petit moment
et parce qu'en plus le précédent le
casque de réalité virtuelle de la ps4 ne
sera pas exploitable sur psa si à merci
julien 6 mai l'adaptateur sera gratuit
et fourni par sony va merci beaucoup
moi j'avais lu j'avais lu une info un
peu trop évasive mais en tout cas où il
n'y a pas de nouveaux jeux vr qui sont
présentés il n'y a pas de nouveaux
casques et jim ryan le patron de sony a
été interrogé là-dessus il a dit oui oui
on croit la dr bien sûr la vr super par
contre vous attendez à rien l'année
prochaine ni l'année suivante d'accord
bon bah soyons pression alors il ya pas
mal de questions qui sam qui
s'amoncellent et notamment des
salutations aussi bonsoir pierrick folie
guèye qui n'ont rejoint sur youtube
merci vous nous rejoignez un peu tard
malheureusement mais là je pense qu'on
va pouvoir couvrir pas mal de questions
avant de se quitter
merci à vous on a aussi des réactions
par rapport à l'électorat de droite un
ça y est on est devenu un vrai même sur
internet et j'en suis très fier parce
que ces figures life qui a initié sa
sueur twitch avec des raids d'antoine
daniel par exemple mais également notre
présence aux event l'année dernière donc
ça c'était plutôt sympa malheureusement
on n'a pas pu y aller cette année à
cause du coc vide mais eric zemmour est
plutôt ps un comics les couloirs on
demandera également à nicolas sarkozy si
on le croise dans les couloirs ça
c'était une question d'un autre
internaute c'était french studio qui
nous demandent s'ils approuvent ah là là
bas on leur proposera la question si on
les rencontre plus sérieusement on à
cette question de tout dogme 64 kg
demande si la xbox et ris xxs pardon
peut lire les disques de jeux 360
alors non oui oui un super alors ça lit
les disques mais park enfin on va te le
disque va servir de clé des quizz nord
voilà ce ça mais il va quand même il va
télécharger en fait le jeu sur internet
mais oui si vous avez le premier red
dead si vous avez le premier dead space
si vous avez bref n'importe quel jeu 360
vous le mettez dans votre console
la console va et télécharger le jeu sur
le xbox live
maintenant le microsoft store ça a
changé de nom et youplaboum vous allez
pouvoir vous amuser avec un jeu qui
arrêté qui va pour bénéficier
d'améliorations par rapport au jeu
original
alors nicolas ne demande sur youtube si
on a reçu déjà la ps1 mais oui vous
l'avez reçu et vous avez pu la tester et
on va vous faire découvrir la son
prochain ouais bah c'est gelé reçu
vendredi dernier la ps5
donc je suis toujours en train de faire
des tests dessus d'essayer les premiers
jeux dont c'est pour ça que j'ai préféré
attendre avant d'en parler sur figaro
live et avant de faire un article sur le
cigare au point fr de l'avoir un peu
plus en pâte
voilà pour les papattes pour voilà faire
un artiste un petit peu complet donc ça
arrive
et voilà attendus la semaine prochaine
je vous dis tout on vous donne rendez
vous en fin de semaine n'hésitez pas à
nos cieux sur twitter pour être un petit
peu prévenu delà de l'heure exacte mais
normand ce sera aux alentours de 19h à
la même heure qu'on a lancé ce live mais
la semaine prochaine pardon à julien la
réalisation à qui j'ai oublié la
question quelles sont les différences
entre la manette de la nouvelle xbox et
la ps1 qu alors à votre avis chloé qui
voit qu'ils avaient pu tester les deux
qu'elles sont calés la meilleure manette
très bonne question alors ce qui
différencie vraiment les deux manettes
c'est les vibrations way sur la manette
de la xbox series x c'est très difficile
à prononcer de la xbox live
x voilà c'est des vibrations classique
sa libération que vous connaissez déjà
un bon moment il n'y a rien de vraiment
exceptionnel et les gâchettes voilà sur
les gâchettes critique normal bref c'est
une manette qu'on connaît déjà
alors que la vallée de la paix 5 déjà
elle propose des vibrations japc des
vibrations hd des vibrations un petit
peu comme je le fais la switch aussi
donc des vibrations qui sont beaucoup
plus sensibles des vibrations qui vous
vous donnez vraiment par exemple
l'impression d'être sous la pluie la
pression d'être en pleine l'averse de
grêle l'impression de marcher dans le
sable l'impression d'être dans la boue
l'impression de marcher dans la neige
mais ça évidemment il faut avoir des
jeux qui font l'effort de développer ces
vibrations et ce n'est franchement pas
le cas de tous les jeux de lancement
bon ça je préfère vous le dire tout de
suite donc ça c'est la première
différence la deuxième différence c'est
ce qu'ils appellent les gâchettes
adaptative dont ce qui veut dire que là
aussi si le développeur a fait l'effort
par exemple quand vous tirer à l'arc
vous pouvez sentir un peu la pression
l'attention de l'arc et donc il va
falloir à payer un peu plus fort vous
allez sentir une résistance qui fait que
ça va ça va rajouter un peu de réalisme
au jeu mais pareil voilà il faut que
l'effort soit fait donc vous avez un jeu
sur ps1 qui montre sa très bien en fait
c'est un jeu qui est inclus dans la
console et qui servent de démo technique
mais c'est aussi un très bon jeu donc
c'est cool qui s'appelle astro playroom
qui vous montre absolument tout ça
par contre après sur les jeux de
lancement c'est quand même assez peu
exploité
donc voila moi ça me laisse un peu
interrogatif en disant est ce que ces
défis turquie sont super cool mais est
ce que là ils vont vraiment être
exploitées par les développeurs c'est
pas certain bon ça c'est l'avenir qui
nous le dira mais si non létaux console
va écouter
ah si un défaut de la manette xbox
elle marche avec des piles donc c'est
chiant vraiment alors cette même si vous
pouvez acheter un adaptateur donc voilà
c'est ce que j'ai mis donc c'est un
chargeur à une batterie vous pouvez
acheter une batterie mais c'est une
patrie spécial qu'il faut acheter un
bien sûr plus avec un chargeur spécial
et au thym j'avais déjà acheté ça à
l'époque de la 360 sénat qui n'est pas
évolué désherbage changer là dessus donc
vous avez toujours des piles or si vous
restez sur l'option pied je vous
recommande chaudement lâcheté des piles
rechargeables bien sûr comme ça ça vous
évitera un de vous ruiner en pile de
polluer la planète en jetant des pilots
tout le temps passe ou là par exemple il
ya des piles qui sont il ya deux piles
qui sont fournis avec la console donc ça
évite les drames de noël genre oh mon
dieu on n'a pas de piles dont vous en
avez 2 conçu avec mais moi les pieds la
zone gris enfin j'en avais plus au bout
de quatre à cinq jours d'utilisation
donc ça va quand même assez vite pour
qu'elles pour qu'elle fonde pour qu'elle
n'ait plus rien donc ça c'est c'est un
défaut alors que la baisse 5 bon bah
c'est une manade qui se recharge
directement sur le secteur voilà c'est
le truc classique on connaît déjà depuis
la ps3 ça se charge par
par batterie alors plus précisément pour
répondre à dieu les césar qu'est ce que
vous pensez chloé d' assassin's creed
valhalla est ce que le jeu vaut le coup
c'est une bonne question
alors oui et oui alors que dieu c'est
dieu c'est que là la saga ne
m'enthousiasmait plus depuis un petit
moment
voilà j'étais un petit peu là c'est que
ce soit toujours toujours la même chose
même le renouvellement d'origine ça
m'avait pas trop pas trop séduit j'ai
fait aussi l'impasse sur odyssée parce
que nous dit bon bah c'est juste la même
chose mais sous le soleil sous le soleil
de la méditerranée
alors que là bas franchement je prends
bien mon pied lui le prendre au hamas
revenons à ba écoute et on va on va
finir lorsqu'on a commencé bien ok en
fait voilà à quel échelon
voilà qui est qu'ils aient fait un bail
que vous allez on va là il est vachement
bien on va on va se séparer alors
faisons très rapidement un petit résumé
de cette console que l'on vient de
tester donc c'était la xbox et risk it
s'est proposée à 499 euros alors c'est
assez imposant assez lourd 4 5 kg c'est
très silencieux mais ça montre jusqu'à
60 degrés en termes de chaleur vous avez
à disposition un catalogue assez
important qui va vous permettre de jouer
de l'autre côté vous avez là series est
ce qui l est un peu plus petit est un
peu plus légère qui coûte beaucoup moins
cher 300 euros mais qui ne disposent pas
d'affichage 4 k ou de lecteur blu ray
voilà pour ce choix
si vous êtes intéressé plutôt par la ps1
qui vont vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine jeudi ou vendredi à
partir de 19h en théorie mais on vous
tiendra au courant par twitter tout cas
rester connecté on
3 avec grand plaisir et justement on va
vous retrouver avant de se quitter vous
dans le chat qui avait été très
constructives avec plein de questions
super agréable comme toujours c'est
toujours un vrai plaisir de parler de
jeux vidéo sur le figaro puisque les
reculs communauté twitter youtube ou
encore figaro sont toujours très
agréable merci pour vos commentaires et
vos questions logan parzival nikos et
des jets style de thomas elisabeth aussi
droff réf
nikos et nicolas dulot césar merci tout
12 64 qui on a vu d'autres on a vu chris
kraus et chris klein sur la page
principale du figaro on vous remercie
et enfin bien sûr twitch ah oui alors je
vous ai cités au passage dans la volée
de youtube mais des jets style woodroffe
ref qui nous suivaient e sur twitch
voilà on vous remercie merci beaucoup
crié pour ce test toujours intéressant
on a toujours plaisir à vous retrouver
pour des tests vidéo ludique
merci à la réalisation à julien qu'une
aile et merci à marie amélie à la
modération
on vous retrouve très vite sur le figaro
rester connectés et à bientôt pour un
nouveau stream
[Musique]